[Music]
people often ask me the question in the
era of AI what jobs and what skills what
I need well first of all let's take a
look at the first era of space
exploration of the 1960s there was a
crash program back then to miniaturize
the transistor that's why our astronauts
like John Glenn they're short people
they were tiny people the Russian
astronauts they're also very tiny
because they have to fit inside the nose
cone of a missile and we scientists were
given the mission to miniaturize
transistors as far as possible now as a
consequence of that we have what is
called the Internet age today all the
goodies you see in your living room all
the telecommunication wonders of the
Internet were in part a consequence of
this mass drive to miniaturize a
transition because we were in the Cold
War with the Soviet Union now as we
enter the second golden era there's
going to be yet another crash program to
miniaturize computers even more
this means transistors made out of
molecules quantum computers a whole new
era of computation so there could be yet
under the golden age of computer
technology emerging because of the
emphasis emphasis placed on going to
Mars with the cheapest lightest possible
object and this means even more computer
power then the other question is well
what are the jobs that are going to be
there in the future well first of all I
tell people that semi skilled work will
will be with us for many decades to come
including garbage men sanitation workers
plumbers policemen gardeners
construction workers you see robots
cannot pick up garbage robots cannot
design a garden robots cannot solve a
crime we forget that robots are very bad
at pattern recognition robots cannot fix
your toilet and they probably won't be
able to for many decades to come in fact
the Pentagon even sponsored the DARPA
challenged to create a Fukushima robot
their job was to take our skills of
today and build a robot that could clean
up Fukushima this means a driving a car
be getting out of the car see sweeping
the floor turning a valve and doing some
simple maintenance work that a
five-year-old kid can do well the
results are on the Internet you can
download them and they're hilarious
you see many robots falling over with
the inability to get up because they're
like an upside-down turtle they're
simply stuck on the floor we have a long
ways to go before we master pattern
recognition at the level of a plumber at
the level of a gardener the job to avoid
in the future however are the middlemen
jobs for example brokers and low-level
tellers and accountants for example
today when you go to a stock broker
you're no longer buy stock now you may
say to yourself that's stupid everybody
knows when you go to a stock broker you
buy stock I mean what else you gonna buy
huh well no you don't buy stock when you
go to a stock broker you can buy stock
on your wristwatch so why bother to go
to stock broker because you want
something that stockbrokers provide that
robots cannot and that is intellectual
capital that means experience know how
savvy innovation talents leadership
none of which none of which computers
and robots can provide so the large
explosion of jobs in the future will be
jobs that robots cannot do ie jobs
involving pattern recognition and jobs
involving common sense as well as
middlemen jobs that involve intellectual
capital creativity products of the mind
those the jobs which are still going to
flourish in the future as 20 Blair of
England likes to say England derives
more revenue today from rock and roll
than it does the coal mining industry
now why is that because coal mining
represents commodity capital commodity
capital yes we'll have it for
for decades centuries to come but it
falls in price every year agriculture
for example today today you had
breakfast that the king of England could
not have had a hundred years ago
think of what you had for breakfast
delicacies from around the world almost
for free
that's because agriculture being a
commodity drops in price because of
better containerization as produce
production shipping better cultural
methods and things like that so this
means that jobs that are intellectual
rather than but that our commodity
related will flourish in the future
[Music]